the old new idea coming up again making
hijra
leaving the west for the east
i myself tried to make hijra to leave
the uk and leave europe three times do
not think that just because you decide
as a muslim
to move to saudi arabia to morocco to
algeria to whatever
that suddenly all these muslims millions
of muslims will welcome you
and you have a family of 20 million
muslims surrounding you
and welcoming you and eat no and this is
the point that i've made that i want to
make actually with the show today
that through my experience of the last
30 years i've come to the point to say
let's make the best out of where we are
and what we are
[Music]
[Music]
if society is so amazing in moral and
progressive and
first world country then why are we
suffering with these internal societal
diseases
things like drinking things like smoking
things like zinna things like music
pornography
why because they don't actually care
about morality
they care about desire
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims
minus one muslim plus another muslim
we're joined here with dr steph karis
after a couple months now salam alaikum
indeed it has been a long time
hamdulillah we've been busy both of us
um summer has come so alhamdulillah the
whole issue with corona has calmed down
a bit
we can travel again which is extremely
important for me at this moment
in order to introduce my work and uh to
be able to sell
uh my my my books and my dvds and
everything
so it was quite important this this this
break in between was very important
but i'm still back i mean i am on social
media as well
and i've done quite some workshops in
the past
um and we have actually started being
extremely busy with workshops online
nowadays
seeing that when we started them during
corona times during the
strong peak of corona actually um we got
a lot of interest from north america
from australia
and we are now trying to juggle the
times when to push them out there
to be australian and american friendly
which is extremely difficult believe me
it's nearly impossible actually but
we're working on it
so for some of our newer viewers a lot
of them should know you
because if they're you know aware of
history and they like history but the
ones that don't really you know
have familiarity with who you are give
like a quick little summary of anything
they want to know
first of all um it has been i think
already three times i've been on
the three muslims i'm had the chance to
meet also the third muslim brother
mashallah
um and we had some excellent
discussions with regards to my work what
is my work i'm a historian
my background is actually i have a phd
in political science as well as in
linguistics languages i speak several
languages and
i've been traveling throughout the world
for the last three four years
introducing um especially my latest book
which is the islamic history of europe
i'm trying to wake up people youngsters
as well
as older people actually about the
influence that islam has had on the west
western education the western system
islam in europe in north america in the
caribbean in australia in africa
what does it mean how did islam really
spread is it really true
that it was spread by the sword or is it
just another myth like many others with
regards to islam and the muslims
myself i'm of greek origin grew up in
germany i'm living in the uk at the
moment
been very busy with the development of
islam in europe
and also the recent development
especially what shook me a lot was
the war in the 1990s the breakup of
yugoslavia a country which was known as
yugoslavia which nowadays has split into
six or seven
entities and out of them actually three
or four mainly muslim ones
and this is something that pushed me
even further to be to expand more into
on on the subject of islam in the west
islam in europe
islam in north america and australia how
did it really spread
and how come that we have now there's
muslims living in europe
we have muslim countries in europe in
the balkan peninsula how come that islam
was actually in america and in australia
long before the europeans arrived there
so this is
just a very rough idea of my work
basically
mashallah
and and look at dr cares that tell me
this man doesn't look good today
that's the first thing i noticed bro
mashallah it's 30 degrees
so we have to enjoy this weather
it's been raining a lot for the last
couple of days really oh my goodness we
have had a wonderful wonderful weather
you know it's like trevor noah keeps
saying the 10 days of summer in the uk
so we're enjoying the 10 days of society
for having me on on the program again i
think
i would like to
[Music]
mention something extremely important
actually today um
in the last couple of weeks and months i
have
had the chance to read a lot of emails a
lot of people have contacted me with
regards to
the old new idea coming up again making
hijra
leaving the west for
the east problem is what does that mean
the definitions of both are extremely
important what is the west what is the
east
what is the muslim world um where can we
go to where can we really make
hijra what does it mean the idea of
hijra
is it something we should really pursue
nowadays as muslims we're living in the
west
um again what does this definition what
is the definition of west again and
how clear is it is there is it black and
white it's
obviously not um and i have been busy
really a lot in the last couple of weeks
and months with
these questions and for myself i mean
the question never stopped i
myself tried to make hijra to leave
the uk and leave europe three times
the last time actually i went back to my
original home country
where i thought that things would be
better simply because i'm greek so i go
back to greece
but let me start with my first uh
attempt to leave europe
i was very naive that time when i
started it was around 20 years ago and i
had hoped that
the muslims in the muslim world would um
receive us with open arms and would just
wait for us to come
european muslims educated people you
know they want their deen they come to
us
that's what i thought they would think
but that's absolutely not the case
there's not
all the way there the muslims and the
arabs and the arab world things
thinks of us rather the opposite i would
say i remember that when i had a job in
saudi arabia i was living in jeddah for
a year
um i remember how some of my colleagues
who
except one they all came from from from
from
the original muslim world coming from
egypt from from the emirates
uh or from other muslim countries jordan
palestinians and so on
and they actually when the time for
salah came you will not believe it
but many of them had an excuse that they
needed to go to the toilet
or they needed you know in saudi arabia
it's like this that when the time for
salah is there
it's officially announced the adhan is
in the school i was working for a school
and we all got getting we're getting
ready to to
to do the congregational prayer and i
was one of the first ones getting up
making wudu and leaving and asking my
colleagues guys
do you have wudhu are you coming and
you will not believe it but most of them
were trying to avoid the salah and
trying to avoid speaking to me because
they saw in me an extreme muslim
a radical one and we're talking about
muslims at the moment yeah
a radical one who is trying to get them
out of their comfort zone to get them to
pray imagine that
the european greek muslim is trying to
get these born muslims to pray
um so that was the first disappointment
already and that didn't go down well
neither with them nor with me so i was
actually we ended up in arguments and
and fight i was a very i'm a hothead
actually but with regards to islam
i did not want to discuss this with
muslims i mean that i had to have
discussions
i did not see myself being in in a
position
leaving the west to come to the muslim
world and to my muslim brothers and
sisters
to have to discuss issues of the salah
the importance of the salah
which i would have had to discuss with
non-muslims in the west and that's why i
left
so that was a massive disappointment i
don't know if you can understand that i
think
maybe you can understand that i think
many others would not really see the
point
um so that was my encounter in saudi
arabia
very close to my encounter later in
dubai the second time i went to dubai to
the emirates
and i had i was a bit more prepared and
see
knowing the emirates already from before
i did not expect sahaba walking on the
street
uh whereas i expected them in saudi
which did not happen obviously
so the same in emirates i saw that there
were normal
arabs working outside of muslims who
cared as much for the deen as many
muslims care here in the west for the
dean
uh although they could hear azan
although they were right next to masjid
although whatever they would you would
rather see them you know
uh smoking the nare rather than going to
the
next door masjid um so
the third time i thought okay let me
really make hijra to my home country
where we have muslims hamdurillah not
necessarily
when my parents have built a house so
not necessarily where i was planning to
go with my family
uh also for reasons of not having to pay
rent and yeah humdilight felt good i was
there for a year i must really say
i must admit that it felt the best of
all three times
i must admit although i was not in a non
i was not in a muslim environment
but i felt i was somewhere back home
okay i really felt that i was in my
father's village
and we were welcome although my wife
comes from a totally different country
totally different background everything
i myself am a muslim and i did not hide
it but for them it was really i was just
one of them
and they did not just discuss this deal
you know that's something i had learned
from my travels
just don't just leave them just do not
discuss the issue of islam
everything else is fine it was fine
indeed and it was all accepted
everything i i could have really it was
really i must really admit it was the
best time i've had of all the three
times that we tried we attempted to make
hijra
in the end um the problem was
financially then i mean
that was the time when greece really
went down
down the wrong side you know it was uh
2009
2010 when the big crisis hit greece
exactly that time and i decided i saw
that something was coming towards us and
i decided to take my children
and instead of leaving towards athens
who were planning to go originally
towards the capital
we decided to come back to the uk again
um so all this i'm telling you basically
it's not just for you too it is
something that the audience should hear
i think because
many have attempted the same many have
tried to go to make hedra to go to the
muslim world
and try to raise their children and
thinking that actually their children
would have a better environment
in the muslim or arab world
avoiding anything that they leaving
behind basically the fitna of europe and
north america
but i've encountered in saudi
in emirates in turkey in morocco in
algeria and egypt wherever i've been
i've seen children having less respect
for the dean of many children having
less respect for the dean than they
would have in the west
i know many muslim children here
mashallah who i respect a lot
and i know that the madrasasi are full i
know that
despite the problems that we might have
here in the west whatever this might be
again we have to
define this this this this word again
this term is very important because
people
simply come up with black and white it's
west and east
the east being the muslim world which is
not at all the case
the west being all the non-muslim fitnah
issues it's not that easy guys
it's not black and white okay and this
is something that i've experienced in my
last 25 to 30 years of being a muslim
of traveling around being in muslim
countries in many of them in a
huge number of them we have more than 50
muslim countries in the world
um they are as puzzled and the people
living in these countries are as puzzled
at the people living in
in the so-called west and again now to
find a definition what is the west
i mean is the west really only north
america
or the americas north and south america
europe in europe we have four muslim
countries
okay in europe we have a massive amount
of muslim minorities
living and thriving in certain countries
in other muslim in other countries in
europe we have muslim minorities
being threatened and feeling alienated
without a doubt
but again in the same continent of
europe where we have more than 50
countries
we have countries such as sweden we have
countries such as the uk
countries such as germany italy and
greece very different countries
i mean they could have all been in
different continents that's how
different they are
it is not the same it's not the same
living in greece as living in sweden it
is not the same living in the uk as
living in germany
and i've experienced all of them so
as a muslim i mean the first thing
first things first actually living as a
foreigner in a foreign country is always
bad
it's always something that makes you
feel you're foreign that's it
so you will you never feel at home
actually because
you have to really well that that was
the reason what triggered that
that was the idea that i had when i went
to greece i thought okay
forget the islamic element i want to
feel somewhere being home
and as i said before i did feel i was
home
although i grew up in germany i have a
very german and a very english education
but still i felt that greek people are
closer to me than german people or
british people or french people or
italian people are
so that in itself i did feel i did feel
being home
in greece rather than being in germany
or the uk no doubt about it
now the islamic element of course came
to it there was no masjid i was in
a village in the northwest of greece
where there was no muslims the only
muslims there were some immigrants
who had to pray somewhere hidden i don't
even know where they prayed not even in
my city where i was there were no
muslims there was no
masjid as far as i know but there was
another city a bigger city further
away around an hour drive from my city
where i met some
immigrant muslims from pakistan and from
other parts of the world
and they told me that they had a mosque
somewhere hidden i don't know what it
was i really couldn't find out i don't
know
what was going on there a very sad
situation honestly for a muslim
in that part of the world so that again
gave me another blow of course it was
something that i was not happy about
and i was also thinking you want to
really raise your children
muslim children in an environment where
you might feel more welcome as a greek
but as a muslim you know
in that part of greece there was nothing
whereas
we decided to go to athens to the
capital where there are many muslims
there are many mosques
there is still things happening the
islamic elements the islamic elements
are there
as much as they can be in in a country
which is non-muslim
um but in the end we decided to come to
the uk and i think it was a good
decision
uh although still i mean i must say i
don't feel welcome here 100
okay i don't feel 100 british
you know what does it mean being british
that's another question again the
british themselves cannot answer that
what does it mean being american i mean
what are british values what are
american values what are german values
what does this all mean
so in the end the conclusion is for all
of us i think after 30 years of
traveling having tried to
the attempts of of of the failed
attempts of hijra
and trying to live in in the muslim
world and trying to establish myself and
my family and my
my children raising them in the muslim
world i've realized that you can raise
your children
in the west depending on where you are
in the west now again it is not the same
living in greece as it is not the same
name in the uk in germany sweden
in the us and within the us again it's
different living in chicago
in new york or in ohio you know so
there are differences you have to choose
and
according to the definition of hedgerow
if you look it up for example and
i've done my homework actually the last
couple of weeks
and indeed scholars have come to the
conclusion to give you actually the idea
of hijra
is not just moving from one non-muslim
country to a muslim country and that's
it
within the same non-muslim country if
you move
from one city or village to another city
or another a city at all
which gives you a more islamic outlook
and gives you an islamic education for
your children and the possibility of
raising your children
yourself being feeling secure and
feeling in an islamic environment being
close to a masjid or whatever it is
islamic community
that in itself is already considered
teacher so we have had people here
coming from the countryside moving over
to london
moving over to east london in east
london we have a very big muslim
community
okay moving from london to birmingham
birmingham has more than 20 muslims the
city of birmingham itself has
more than 20 muslims we have certain
areas where we just have muslims
okay so that in itself is again
considered hijab
so i've come to this i'm giving you all
this
these these these ideas here simply
because
i would like to i'm answering actually
other questions i'm replying to the
questions that i've received
in the last couple of weeks and months
via email or
simply messages that they were written
to me
and i think it's quite important for our
audience here
to um get a little bit an idea of
somebody who has tried in the last 30
years to make hijra
who has come to conclusion to say yes it
is not ideal
living here but it's not id living in
saudi arabia either and it's not ideal
living in morocco
or whatever else you decide to go um
open your eyes be careful people down
there
can really they don't care about you
practicing muslim from the west
with a naive background and
understanding trying to live somewhere
in the countries where they don't want
to be
because they rather would like to be in
new york in chicago or the uk
then and you are going to the countries
where they want to leave
they want to leave these countries
because they think it's better living
in a country somewhere in the west in
europe or in north america
simply because of the financial benefits
that you might get and again that's
something we we cannot underestimate
it is not nothing living in a country
where you get child benefit for having
children
okay which in itself is not a non-muslim
invention it's not something european
german british french whatever it is
something that actually originates
in the muslim world it comes from the
time of the khilaf
child benefit is not an invention from
the west so subhanallah
so we praising them for that and we are
trying to actually
um improve our lifestyle without a doubt
that's what we should do
but we're not thinking further we're not
looking further
and this is the point that i've made
that i want to make actually with the
show today
that through my experience of the last
30 years i've come to the point to say
let's make the best out of where we are
and what we are
um yes always striving for the best and
always trying to give
your children and yourself the best
education but let's look at education in
the west and let's see the opportunities
we have
i've had the chance to actually sell my
books islamic history in europe
rather in europe you know amongst the
non-muslims and amongst the muslims who
grew up
as second and third generation here who
are lost who are trying to find their
identity
then amongst the muslims somewhere in
other parts of the muslim world because
they don't see
that as important okay whereas our
generation second third fourth
generation
european muslims american muslims
understand
the issue of identity search of
trying to find yourself within this type
of society
secular or non-muslim society
and trying to actually raise yourself
and your children
with certain values which uh
should actually be uh also western
values should be values
for families living in the west as well
these are not just values for us muslims
i mean
love your father and your mother um
and respect for your father and your
mother for the elders
um love your wife raise your children uh
giving them morals these are all
um values that anybody in the west would
agree to
so um this is my very long intro and
prelude actually
and bismillah just just shoot with some
questions if you have both of you
so we can come back into this topic
actually mashallah
so would you say it's uh it's a case of
the grass is not growing on the other
side
type deal absolutely subhanallah
that's exactly what i'm saying yes and
a question how important do you think it
is to
have this community of uh
other practicing muslims i do not think
that um
you yourself and your family uh really
being firm in the dean
is uh more than enough or do you feel
like that community is something that
can take it to the next level um
having living in a certain part of the
world
um doesn't mean that you you should not
create a community
that's that's the next step you live
somewhere that's what you do
you work for your family you what you
earn your living that's right
but the next step is actually creating a
community wherever you are
and even if you are living in the in in
the muslim world
you realize that you also have to create
your community do not think that just
because you decide as a muslim
to move to saudi arabia to morocco to
algeria to whatever
that suddenly all these muslims millions
of muslims will welcome you
and you have a family of 20 million
muslims surrounding you
and welcoming you and eat no during eat
they go to their family where do you go
you have no family your family is your
family that's you know am i you know
that's that's what you're carrying with
you every day
that is your family so do not expect any
muslims out in egypt or in saudi arabia
to open their doors and the houses to
you just because you
are a muslim coming from the west no
they don't even think further they don't
even think that you
don't have a family to go to the only
family you have is you and your wife and
children that's it
you don't have to go to your parents
because your parents are not muslims
most of the times
okay so that that's something they don't
think about
and they're not being told it's
something that we mentioned sometime
like you remember during ramadan
when i was on the show and i mentioned
the issue don't forget
during iftar your brothers and sisters
who really suffer at this moment
it's like going for the prayer and
basically
um going back home again
having bought some sweets maybe if you
have children at least you can enjoy the
children the children enjoy you whatever
maybe watching a movie together family
movie that's basically all we do
right because there is nobody and
nothing else we can do in the west
so and don't expect um
sorry i just got you
okay don't expect the uh
muslims in that part of the world to
understand you because for them
they've taken it for granted they've
taken the advan for granted the first
time i heard adam i was in turkey
i started crying the first time i went
into masjid again it was in turkey i
fell down and just
prostrated and people were looking at me
like what's wrong with him
so you know they take it for granted we
have to understand that
that these people they're hearing
they're done five times a day
seeing the magnificent mosques on a
daily basis
while they're working home school or
away from them
you know they consider that they take
this for granted
and we need to finally wake up we
muslims in the west
now we need to create our community
wherever we are
so coming back to your question we need
to create our community we will have to
create our community
in order to get our children again
familiarize them with other muslims of
course what are you going to do you
cannot lock yourself up at home
and say you know the others are living
somewhere miles away no you need to
get your children to come in contact
with other muslim children as well
you need to get them to the community
let's call it the community meaning
other muslims
who share the deen with you you need to
take your children to the masjid
you need to go to the mosque as much as
you can and
the worst thing you could really do is
living in the west and living isolated
from the muslim community
i guarantee you there's the end and the
death of
your children and of your islam it's
going to be just you
dying as the only muslim praying you
know
so no yes rather yes we have to create
our community wherever we are
be it in a muslim or non-muslim world
yes
i had something on my mind that i wanted
to share so when you were mentioning
that
it's oftentimes the muslims that weren't
even by your side it reminded me of when
we started this podcast right on how's
down my family's down
friends are down they're supporting the
cause right i've extended found because
i'm from bangladesh
right i have extended family finding out
about my podcast and they're like
yo uh they're like calling my parents
right
like hey we heard uh if i had started an
islamic podcast
like you know what happens to a lot of
youth right
when they're like in their early adult
years and they start you know
becoming more radical and then i'm like
bro are you are you
are you serious bro like are you
literally serious bro
and it's like it reminded me of a lot of
uh people i know back home
in bangladesh they start youtube like
dollar channels and all that
and you could tell them anything you
could tell your parents you could tell
family
oh i'm starting this channel i'm
starting a cooking channel i'm starting
this
i'm starting a vlog channel as soon as
you bring islam into it
or your extreme what happened yeah what
happened to you yeah you have problems
can we help you is there something yeah
um it's uh
subhanallah you're absolutely right for
it i mean this is something that i've
experienced with friends of mine
who have a muslim background right um
and it's typical i mean
they seem to have bigger problems with
their brains than we have i mean our
parents have accepted now
my parents have not accepted again a
muslim he's anyway gone
that's it whatever he does he does but
it seems like
uh born muslim parents it seems like
they're trying it i mean continuously to
get you off the deen and
um for them it seems like it's the end
of the world when they see their
daughter
coming back with a hijab so not leaving
with hijab or coming back with a job so
they know their daughter because they
never educated their daughter
islamically
for them it's important rather their
daughter is becomes a successful lawyer
or successful doctor that is a success
in their in their in their eyes
but if their daughter covers up suddenly
she becomes extreme you're putting
problems in your way you're making it
difficult for your sister
you're making it difficult that's what
they tell the the own parents i remember
a case
of a muslim sister masha'allah who
believe it or not
she was from france very difficult
country of course to be from
and i met her and her husband in
istanbul in turkey
and she was covered everything normal as
i expected right
but she told my wife she told us we were
going out we had some days together in
istanbul
great great time mashallah we met these
brothers and sisters and
it was really fine from france and she
was telling us for example she said when
i go
back to france and they come and pick us
up from the airport i have to take
remove my hijab i said what she said yes
not because of the french who make it as
difficult as possible because of my
parents
she says and they were algerian origin
so subhanallah these are the things that
really disappoint a
a new muslim entering the dean you have
to really make sure when you enter the
dean you enter the dean for the dean
and not for a wife you want to have or
for a friend you want to do something
good or a favor you want to no
no no you enter the deen for the deen do
never do it for the muslims
never do it for the muslims you know and
i remember i remember
how hamza uh yes of islam actually you
all know use of islam right
the cats cat stevens the singer cat
stevens in the 70s
who became muslim he used to live in
london i met him actually in london
he's of cypriot origin greek separator
is actually he's of greek origin like me
but his um stepmother was cypriot as far
as i understood
so and i spoke to him i met him twice
actually in london
and this quote everybody knows you know
i'm happy that i met
islam before i met the muslims
okay this is sad
for a born muslim this is extremely sad
you know
that we have to say these things i agree
fully i agree 200
with what he said i'm also happy that i
met islam i understood islam
before i came across muslims although i
did
i grew up with muslims i had turkish
students who were together with me my my
i mean my peers in class i grew up with
turkish
turkish
turkish guys and i'm good friends
and but we never spoke about islam
because they themselves never prayed
they didn't know anything about islam so
um how pathetic is that that you grow up
with muslims
but you have never heard of islam you
don't know anything about islam
okay and the very same people are by by
the way and i want to mention that as
well
one of these people from that time who
we were close were going out discourse
parties and everything
this very same person i met some years
back when i was back in germany
i met him on the street and i was like
man what's happening what's going on
what he saw me and he realized obviously
you know i've become extreme i'm having
a beard and all this stuff so
um it was like bro yeah you know you're
still muslim
yeah alhamdulillah i i you know
i'm yes of course i'm muslim are you
of course i'm a turk listen to the the
the answer
i'm turkish so i'm muslim i said no no
no no brother you see
you haven't understood that's exactly
what i'm talking about
you're not muslim because you're turkish
you're a muslim because you're a muslim
because you understood the deen you're
not muslim because you're turkish or
arab or whatever you are no
no and this very same person
asked me to teach him how to make wudu
believe it or not
he asked a greek guy how to teach him
how to make wudu
not only this i'm greek there's a
turkish guy asking a greek guy
you know and you know the hostility and
animosity between the greeks and the
turks
and i'm a greek muslim you know and i
have to teach the turkish muslim
actually you should come to me
you know i have to teach him how to make
with him i asked him bro you know what
about your father what's he doing
he had a head heart issue and everything
yeah yeah indeed he said
he is struggling with his heart what
does he do every friday instead of going
to the masjid he actually
sits in front of a tv 220 turkish tv
channels he has and he goes from one tv
channel to the other
you know it's like it's a common thing
in german that you have amongst turkish
guest workers as they were called that
time
that you have them now totally
into their turkish series and into the
turkish channels
into their going back home type of
mentality you know
after having been in germany for 40 50
years having raised their children and
their grandchildren into in germany
and still having this back home
mentality and not looking at all that
what they miss
actually rather islam than being turkish
or whatever this might be
so his father was zapping from one
program to a turkish program to the
other
not having shown his child how to make
wudu or actually how to perform a salah
imagine that so much about born muslims
and so much about the disappointment
that you can have
with people who have come who have not
entered the deen out of their own will
they just happen to be muslims because
their parents come from a certain area
which happened to be muslim because when
before it became islamic by the way it
was not
before these first muslims in turkey
became muslims they were not
so you know i mean this is against
something
we don't realize that you know and these
people don't realize that and i've had
in lectures already
um people breaking down in front of me
after i've spoken the way i spoke
although it might seem harsh but i think
sometimes you need to wake them up in
that way you need to shake them up
and it might again as i said it might
seem harsh and sound harsh
and some people took it the wrong way
but in general i think i
um have shaken up people and i think
that's what i want to do with my
lectures as well
so you don't let the comments get to you
and
no i hope no no not really no
no no i think that um
rather that the 10 people that's going
to be
annoyed and irritated will be balanced
out with 100 people who will not be who
will be woken up inshallah and shaken up
that's what i believe in hope
inshallah inshallah
i mean when it isn't matter who who says
what right that's the world we live in
we can't change our message to to
fit today's narrative there is no doubt
about it we have to be diplomatic let's
call this
i mean big word now here i know i mean
our parents like this i myself
would tell my children now be diplomatic
the way you come out and you say things
i mean
we have to as muslims nowadays justify
our deal
we have to nowadays come out there and
be diplomatic with regards to the lgbtq
community for example we have to be
diplomatic right now what does that mean
that we cannot really
say openly what we really believe you
cannot
and on the and then they are telling you
you're living in a democratic society
you're living in a society where you can
there's a freedom of this free speech
right
that's the idea the idea is that we can
utter our opinion freely
can we that's a big question mark i put
behind it with regards to certain issues
on certain people we cannot
we cannot this is hypocrisy you can you
can let women wear what they want but
now
in the european union they banned hijab
in the workplace right
they say that yes absolutely absolutely
an and an employer
can actually um clearly state the reason
of not employing somebody simply because
they're winning a job yes
they can do that yes absolutely and this
is another disgrace with regards to the
european union
you know and this is something that you
know if i look back
the time of brexit in the uk for example
when they started going for the idea of
brexit
we were very upset as europeans living
in the uk of course it has affected us
directly of course but i can
they didn't do it of course for islamic
reasons but as a muslim i can fully
understand and rather support
the idea of brexit at this moment
because in britain for example
the laws have not changed and would not
change at this moment
as the wind does in the european union
for example you know if you look at the
european muslims at this moment on the
continent
they suffer more than we do in the uk
british muslims
we couldn't have have had it easier here
actually
our women there's never an issue as a
woman with a hijab
you might come across employers who
would have a problem but i'm very honest
i don't think it's going to be more than
10 to 20 percent of employees okay which
means 80 percent
would accept you with hijab finally you
move on but it's the opposite on the
continent
on the continent in germany for example
the situation where i know very well in
germany i know sisters
who couldn't even be at the register
because they were wearing a hijab
can you explain the logic in there i
mean the sister is working at the
register
at the supermarket what is the problem
she's wearing or not wearing a job what
is the issue
you know what is what does tesco or
costco
or whoever else what do they ask that
what do they have to keep up what kind
of reputation is that
neutral they're saying in germany
neutrality
so you are neutral because you tell a
girl who's wearing a job to take the
hijab off
that's neutral i call this oppression
i'm sorry that's for me the same
then telling somebody uh to actually
wear the hijab it's exactly the same
thing
if i oppress my wife telling my daughter
i tell her
you have to you must wake up from now on
because i tell you so i'm your father
whoever
that's the same way of oppressing my
daughter as
the employer in germany can now say i
want you to take the hijab off because
we want to be neutral we're in a neutral
environment
germany loves throwing around with this
word neutral
what does this mean so neutrality means
oppressing your wife who's wearing hijab
taking the hijab or forcefully
that's neutral that's clearly taking
sides for me i don't see the neutrality
there i'm sorry
so it is a disgrace for the european
union and it is a disgrace for the
europeans
to to really react in such a way
absolutely disgrace so for me honestly i
fully understand the discussion
that has flared up again with regards to
hydra and wanting to move away from
europe especially i fully understand
that
but again europe is not all europe is
not the same
you know living in sweden is not the
same like living in greece or in germany
or in the uk
if you have a problem in sweden try to
find another country within the european
union where you can live better
italy has many positive sides spain has
many positive sides
um you know maybe even the netherlands
you know i've lived in holland for a
while i know it has changed but it is
better than living in
certain oppressive regimes such as in
france or in belgium for example
okay so as much as you can you you move
on brothers you move on
okay and try to move on within within
the possibilities that you get and you
you have and do not go crazy do not just
grab your luggage as we did
grab a bag grab your two-year-old and
say we're making hijra and going to
whatever
it doesn't work that way you know keep
your head in the game
find out what you need you want to make
hydra become an english teacher
okay learn english do your celta your
cambridge certificate
go out to the muslim world they love you
because you're teaching them something
that they want to know english
now you're fleeing english but you're
going with this english
you're making a new life you're just
building up your life in the muslim
world
where you feel happier maybe okay and
you have a fight you have an income you
cannot go and live in the muslim world
without any income problems you cannot
do that
so let's not be living in the dream
world you know
so let's be realistic you want to do
something
and i'm speaking to my english speaking
brothers and sisters masha'allah
the best thing that we have in the
english speaking world is
the english language grab it take it
become an english teacher do yourself or
your cambridge certificate
and go and teach it takes one month a
thousand pounds
grab a thousand pounds together go for
one month do your best
and become an english teacher with a
cambridge certificate and go and work
out in the emirates in in saudi in
qatar in kuwait there are jobs out there
for you and you can
you can get a good payment okay and you
can inshallah because you will have a
good payment
and you have you will have a um
a good life actually for your family you
can enjoy life in in double ways you
know you have your islam
and you have your financial uh security
so that's what i'm
i'm i'm really my children are mashallah
i mean they don't
want to become english teachers but one
thing that i told the older ones now
everybody who's above 18. one thing
my very my older one he is into islamic
banking mashallah
okay he's done islamic banking which is
great for him but i pushed him also to
do his thefalees
teaching english as a second language
certificate he did it online mashaallah
okay he sees the the benefit he gets
with that
because with this certificate he would
rather get a job in
um in the emirates or in dubai or in
or in qatar in kuwait rather than with
islamic banking let's be honest they
don't they don't want islamic banking
man they don't want islamic banking
actually exactly
exactly you know that's rather something
for the west you know
rather something for yourself to develop
yourself and to do something on your own
absolutely absolutely so the same my
second younger one now he's doing i.t
well he's also busy with his staff with
his uh
english degree so that's what i i really
my suggestion would be really oh my my
advice would be to anyone here
yes anyone who's living in the
english-speaking world knows english
well enough
please do your english certificate
degree
it doesn't take you longer than one
month you will not believe it one month
one thousand pounds which is around
fifteen hundred dollars isn't it around
you know do your celta cambridge
certificate
get qualified and certified by cambridge
as an english teacher
and you will inshallah find a job out
there okay if this is your dream
you want to live in the muslim world
then really become an english teacher
i'm sorry maybe you might not
not like teaching but there's one dream
that supports
um another dream maybe so so you know
this is something i would
i let's buy advice basically and that's
what i tell people who speak english
now somebody who doesn't speak good
english or comes from from from germany
or from other parts of the world
they have it more difficult now i know a
german brother
who has been you know for the last 10
years actually mashallah
has moved to um
he has moved to qatar masha'allah and
he's doing quite well there and he's an
architect
he's from germany and he's an architect
okay so
they want educated people down there
okay get an education from the west get
western languages
and go down there and teach them or go
down there and teach
these people down there what they want
from you what you're running away from
okay no matter do it you know you're
running away from something they want to
come to to that what you're running away
to
give it to them because that's your
improvement save yourself and your
family from the hellfire allah says in
the quran
he doesn't say save your community and
your world and your land your country
and your people
save yourself and your family from the
hell fire
so save yourself and your family from
hell fire
okay you don't need to look into the the
rest of the world you know
so save yourself that's it that's that's
basically the last thing that i'm
gonna save yourself how are you gonna
save others right sorry
if you can't save yourself how are you
gonna save other people absolutely i
mean start with yourself
don't forget when you're on the plane
what do they say
if something happens you have to wear
your the mask first yourself and then
your child
your child then you take care of your
son or daughter you have to wear refresh
yourself because if you don't wear it
and you worried your son by the time
that you have to have to wear yours
you're that you're dead
that's it fine end of story so
let's be realistic i think i really call
it pragmatism and realism
i think muslims have have forgotten to
be realistic nowadays and i think our
ancestors were actually quite realistic
in the past talking about history if you
look at our
ancestors in the past you see them being
very pragmatic and quite realistic
okay don't forget rasulullah when they
had prisoners of war
what did they do with them he would
actually give them
their freedom if they taught the muslims
how to read and write
if they told the muslims another
language if they told the muslims
if they educate the muslims they would
give them freedom he would give them
freedom the non-muslims
they're non-muslim prisoners of war
subhanallah look
isn't i mean how much more pragmatic can
somebody get
isn't this pragmatism and realism
and nowadays we are flying on on on
clouds
you know we really think that you know
we can go and find the sahaba walking
on the street in general you know
no no that's not the way it was
you know so well let's wake up and
that's what i wanted to say subhanallah
and zakala for the opportunity that was
given really i honestly believe that
because of all the feedback that i got
also in the questions in the past
um i think it needed to be said i mean i
keep saying that in my lectures i keep
saying that those are my workshops
and to my audience but i think it is
important that other people who might
not be my audience
i think they need to hear that too
simply because of this is an experience
of a 50 year old muslim
who became muslim 30 years ago who has
really traveled the world
knows a variety of languages has come in
contact with
i would dare saying all people in the
world
you know and have come to a certain
conclusion now
okay i have a big family alhamdulillah i
have seven children myself
okay so again this
counts as much for me as it comes for
everybody else
save yourself and your family first okay
and how you think that you can save
yourself this is something that you as
an individual have to figure out
for some it might be hijra so-called it
might be moving to a certain city
country or whatever
where it's better for some it might just
simply be in the community where they
are to improve
that community or themselves in their
community
okay let's not again let's not dream
let's not live in dream world
okay let's be realistic and pragmatic
and subhanallah i like how you put in a
very practical way and
it's very realistic because i think
that's something that everyone needs to
hear nowadays especially
the people watching this channel uh the
men and the women
because it's like we live in a time
where
resources are abundant we live in a time
where
you could also make your own source of
income online
but it's like if something were to
happen you need a skill you need
something that's tangible like a trade
that
if the online word of drop you can still
provide for yourself and for the people
you're with your family
or the community or something like that
but it's like
you get something online like let's say
me personally i have a coaching business
online
alhamdulillah excellent i'm very
grateful i'm very grateful
but if something would happen and then
the internet would have dropped
right there's no more electricity like
okay then then what do i do
if i don't have a trade if i don't have
a skill so i feel like what you just
said
very important was like english only
takes one month
not a lot of money gives you something
that's like
you have it in your belt where it's like
something happens you can whip it out
and you can use it for that so yeah i
like i like that and i also think that
if the people watching don't want to do
english
will then see it as like a gateway to
open you up to something different like
look
at other skills as well other trades
that you can
maybe invest your time and energy into
to have something you know in the back
just in case something were to happen
or if you want to make the hijra
absolutely i mean
based on this one i hope i didn't
interrupt you brother but you just said
very good
the issue of english was really that it
might be not everybody can be a teacher
but there is another thing again what
you just said and i wanted to come back
to that
become a plumber we all try nowadays for
example subhanallah we all tried to get
our children
myself mashallah my mother she was
pushing me towards
getting an education i am hamdulillah i
am the person i would be i have two left
hands
okay so it is really difficult for
somebody like me to become a plumber but
you know what if i had to
i would have been able to become a
plumber i know that so now
um i know plumbers for example nowadays
you know how difficult
it has been the last three months we've
been looking for a plumber
you will not believe for the last three
months we have been looking for a good
plumber by the way we've had people
coming coming and going
we had a problem with the shower now you
will not believe you will i don't know
if you
you will not believe me for three months
i've been looking for a plumber three
months
we were washing with a bucket so finally
we got the shower night sold we finally
got a plumber
so i'm saying also please the skills
you're talking about it's not on
teaching is one one example that i can
give you which i think will all cover us
all because we all speak english we are
living in the
english-speaking world we all grew up
with english language martial art we can
we could theoretically do all that
but next to this one yes there are some
people who cannot do that so there might
be handy people out there
who rather be plumbers builders
we need these people we really think the
internet you're absolutely right angel
is great while we are doing all of us
we're all running internet businesses
here now
all three of us but what what
if once we're all dependent on the
internet what if there's no electric a
big blackout
what if one's there is the end of
internet what if what
what do you do then what do you do then
tell me
okay so yes absolutely and again
go back to history look at the sultans
of the ottoman empire
subhanallah the sultan there were
sultans that were actually
shoemakers believe it or not they knew
how to make shoes
that was their skill they had learned
how to make schools
shoes shoe makers and they were sultans
they were most of them were even poets
okay they were used they would use
poets or vegan being being a boat they
would use it actually just as
as as a leisure pastime okay it's
something they would do
in the past time however however
some of them you know have become even
famous for the poetry that they wrote
okay and there were some of them who
were very handy
subhanallah so again we are not learning
from the past
whenever i say learn from history it's
not an empty slogan that people use
nowadays you know yeah i keep asking
nowadays they all know me
you know when i ask when i go to a city
i know they've watched me
they have seen some of my lectures
already and when i ask i know the answer
when i ask like what why is it why is
history important to us so they will all
say
you will hear now to say the answer you
have to learn from our mistake
great they wouldn't do that three four
years ago but nowadays they all do that
okay
the problem is now it's it has become an
empty slogan what does it really mean to
you
now you might have heard it you might
have maybe heard me saying that
but what does it really mean to you now
what does it mean
what will you do with this knowledge yes
we have to learn that's absolutely right
that's the answer it's a correct answer
we have to learn from our mistakes but
don't make it an empty slogan
it should really mean something to you
when you say that
learn from our mistakes learn from the
past just
20 years ago the boston i'm just reading
something in boston in war again i'm
just reading about the
breakup of yugoslavia in the 1990s
between 1992 and 1995
the 11th of july again we remembered the
massacre of srebrenica we remembered the
genocide that happened in
in in bosnia now who really
remember to be very honest it's a small
circle of people
a small circle of people who oh yeah
yeah 1992 1995.
how many of us really know still
remember 1992 to 1995.
how many of us really now know what
happened how many of us know how many
people died during that war
how many of us know what the muslims
went through you know even
even in bosnia nowadays it's just put
under the carpet it's swept under the
carpet just leave it
let it go let it go why being reminded
of it every time
why because i'm not here to open your
wounds that's not the idea
my idea is we have to never forget this
and i mean never forget i'm not talking
about some never forget this ending
you know never forget ending story you
know some kind of empty slogans again
which you will find i was in the gambia
i was in the gambia and i went to this
life island there for example and it
said
never forget you know what are you
talking about i to laugh
i to laugh what are you talking about
honestly honestly
the empty slogan that it said on the
island never forget the same it says in
auschwitz
never forget yeah that's a nice slogan
it says it up there
but do we really follow the slogan it
has become an empty slogan
it's empty there's nothing behind it
anymore nothing
and a very good brother told me once a
bosnian brother he said the best thing
i tell you allah he said the best thing
that happened to us boss nancy said is
the war the war was the best thing that
happened to us
and i looked at him and i was i was
shocked for a moment i was shocked but i
didn't understand what he meant
he said we our women did not know what
hijab was they didn't even know how to
spell hijab
before the war our men
had always seen the mosque from outside
they knew what they looked like the
minerals
the pointy ottoman minerals but they had
never been inside a mosque
imams knew surat al-fatiha that was all
they knew
some of them didn't even subhanallah so
the best thing that happened to the
bosnians was the wall
and that really shook them and woke them
up many of them
although if you hear nowadays again
stories
i don't know you know i think we need a
much
bigger shake-up an earthquake okay
so subhanallah let us get the earthquake
here now with the show maybe rather than
with the real earthquake
because may allah really be on our side
when something like this happens again
because you know honestly i do i don't
think
and i was asked recently when i was in
southampton again
do you believe something like this can
happen again
i said honestly you asked me this
question this question that you asked me
this question that you doubted maybe no
question
i hear it the doubt in the question that
in itself already shows me that yes
it will happen again yes
it will happen again just the question
and the doubt in the question
tells me that it will happen again do
you understand that
shocking subhanallah subhanallah so
it's it's not enough to know
but we must do we must act on whatever
it is that
we know from the past and it's better to
act
before something happens because like
that war that
your uh your friend was saying well you
said that was the best thing that
happened
well why was it the best thing that
happened well because the war
forced everyone to start doing to start
acting
but it's like they could have done that
before the war yeah
you know so it's panel
things that people need to know yeah
you're good you're good honestly
everything you're saying
is amazing um for those that are going
to receive it they're going to receive
it for those that don't and may allah
make it easy for them to receive it
but this is something practical this is
something real that i feel like
everybody needs to get on because i
if one of you know this quote it's like
uh wise men
they say uh wise men learn from other
people's mistakes
or something like that right i'm
butchering it 100 on butchering
but you understand it's like look
we have the past we have all these
things that are available
for us to see like what's been going on
and um
look we have the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam who's literally telling
us
that it's all going to come to an end
like
the end times are going to happen when
this happens when this happened with
this happen then
and subhanallah all these things that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has said has been
coming to fruition so it's like if
that's not enough for you to start
seeing like ah okay i should probably
bust down and start you know taking care
of what i gotta take care of learning
what i gotta learn
doing what i gotta do then i don't know
what is
you know and i think it all coincides
everything that we're saying here it all
coincides
so yeah man guys if you made it this far
comment down below hashtag
history series because a lot of people
don't know that we started a history
series
a while back but we've all been busy and
we got a little bit caught up
but we intend to start that up again so
i believe we made
two or three episodes so we'll start
with episode four inshallah very soon
again for whoever wants to know more
about my work stephcurrys.com and i
think you're going to put it in the
in the link down link in the description
yeah exactly in the description
and we have workshops every last uh
every end well the last two weekends or
the last weekend of the month
it will be in english one in english one
in german workshops which
go back to the dynasties of islam they
go back to
our identity in the west it's really
that people believe it's just some kind
of historical
you know data that they're going to get
no no no it's it's it's really very as
we just spoke it's very realistic very
pragmatic
and i want to come to solutions i want
to talk the first workshop we started in
january this year actually
and it was with regards to identity in
the west what does it mean
being a muslim in north america in
australia and europe what does it
actually mean
and we um in the workshop we give them
some
some some case studies we give them
actually some ideas of you know
muslims in america the problems they
face uh how long have they been muslims
in america by the way
uh it's not something that just happened
some some years ago decades ago
centuries ago actually um the same in
europe and so on and so on and then in
the end we come to
to to the problems and we give you
inshallah also
based on our experience and our ideas we
give you some solutions to that you know
and some of them were mentioned today
actually already um
and i believe that there are solutions
we cannot just talk about the topics
as many old men doing the cafes in
greece for example you see them sitting
there
you know and discussing the latest
problems that they face with their
uh grandsons or grand granddaughters um
and oh how bad how how deep how
problematic and everything yeah but what
is the solution
we can discuss the issues but we have to
also discuss the solutions we have to
find solutions
so that's what we're doing inshallah
with the workshop so whoever wants to
know more about it
come to staffcares.com find out when we
have workshops
and what we're discussing there and
again as i said it's not just some
kind of um kind of empty slogans or
um historical facts that we're
discussing no out of history
we take the historical facts and the
the the the ideas that we get from
history and we
implement them actually on nowadays and
we try to understand how we find
solutions to the problems
nowadays based on the understanding of
the past so alhamdulillah i really think
that
um again i have to thank you
uh the three muslims for having invited
me and we will go on insha allah we will
have some more
of these programs inshaallah it was i
hope it was a
shake to wake up today um a bit more
pragmatic and realistic uh more than i
normally am but i think it needs to
happen once in a while it just needs to
happen
it needs to be there hundred percent
why yes all right guys until next time
salaam alaikum warahmatullahi
if society is so amazing in moral and
progressive and
first world country then why are we
suffering with these internal societal
diseases
things like drinking things like smoking
things like zinna things like music
pornography
why because they don't actually care
about morality
they care about desire
[Music]
[Music]
um